j'ai déjà dit que je prenais 2000 ans
dans le camion et que je prenais 2000
voir 2005 plus ici mais maintenant que
j'ai plus de camion quasiment j'ai que
ici le salaire que j'ai touché le mois
dernier j'ai touché 3188 voilà mais ça
c'est pas du bruit
c'est beaucoup plus après il y a les
impôts qui arrivent derrière 3100 il
reste 3100 c'est génial mais c'est
génial tu peux me donner les 88
bah je peux surtout reparler
d'augmentation que je devais avoir ce
qu'on est pas il doit
avoir une augmentation je devais avoir
une augmentation moi cette année avec
les ce que tu me dis là tu l'as eu
des émissions quand même toi aussi toi
tu es prêt à le dire oui moi je m'en
fous parce que je gagne pas d'arriver
voilà je suis arrivée des émissions par
euh moi je prends 500 balles par soir
ici encore
brut en facture en facture prestation en
prestation artistique par contre ce qui
est beau 905 250
et ce qui est beau avec ce reportage
c'est que là juste avant pendant le
magnéto Mathieu m'a confié qu'on avait
gagné par mois
il me l'a dit et en vrai attends on en
parle et en vrai
je sais pas quoi non mais pas du tout
mais c'est un beau chiffre et c'est qui
le connards
vous savez quoi voilà c'est très simple
sur l'argent c'est que moi je le dis pas
c'est
un truc d'éducation catholique parce
qu'en fait à partir du moment où on
donne un montant si toi tu gagnes plus
que toi ou que tu gagnes plus que toi on
commence à regarder les gens avec une
sorte de hiérarchie ou avec Raymond tu
es plus brillant que j'entends que plus
brillant que machin et donner l'argent
c'est c'est une échelle sur les gens
moi je vais très honnête géniaux aucune
idée de de vos revenus
mais c'est surtout par rapport à
l'extérieur parce qu'on est payé de
manière indécente par exemple
pourquoi non parce qu'en fait
aujourd'hui il y a un dicta de la
transparence ou quoi qu'on dise en fait
ce sera un dessin et donc on va nous
dire mais est-ce que tu es légitime toi
parler tous les soirs de telles choses
de tel mouvement social alors que toi tu
es effectivement tu es nanti tu es
extrêmement privilégié et évidemment
c'est le cas tu es donc hors sol et
c'est évidemment le cas et pour autant
j'ai connu la galère j'ai connu des
problèmes des gros problèmes de fric je
sais ce que c'est que de ne rien avoir
je sais que ce que c'est que de ne rien
avoir le dise du mois j'ai été poursuivi
par les huissiers avec ma maman donc je
sais ce que c'est tout ce que je peux
dire c'est que quand j'ai été puisque
c'est des métiers précaires quand les
mannequins on travaille pas plus que à
25 ans après on est on sent le sapin je
crois que j'ai écrivain
et ben c'est pas le même travail puisque
moi pour un défilé je pouvais être payé
par exemple à l'époque je sais pas 10000
ou 15000 euros pour un défilé et pour
défilé de maquereaux et pour écrire un
livre alors que ça me prenait un an de
mon temps c'était 2000 euros la valoir
donc voilà donc il y a à peu près tous
les tarifs on peut avoir aussi tous les
tarifs en tant que artiste ou alors
est-ce que vous considérez comme comme
riche aujourd'hui
moi c'est moi je suis un pour moi la
richesse c'est d'être propriétaire
d'avoir un témoin ici autour de la table
et c'est vrai qu'il y a toujours cette
question qui se pose et je la pose au
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent c'est
vrai que maintenant tout le monde donne
son salaire sur les réseaux etc à partir
de quel somme au partir de quoi vous
considérez comme étant riche
Géraldine moi ma grand-mère par exemple
elle a un petit appartement qu'elle a
acheté grâce à ma maman et tout ça grâce
à ce qu'on lui a donné donc je considère
qu'elle est à l'abri ma mère elle est
pas encore propriétaire elle a bientôt
elle doit travailler jusqu'à 70 ans pour
être propriétaire là et quand moi
j'aurai un petit appartement à moi
propriétaire là je considérais que je
suis riche d'accord moi je suis
locataire je peux pas être propriétaire
je suis trop vieille pour emprunter donc
je considère que je ne suis pas riche
mais je suis très très élevée j'aime
bien j'aime bien savoir vous et je suis
sûr que c'est intéressant pour les
téléspectateurs vous euh à partir de
quand vous vous considérez comme alors
déjà moi je me considère comme riche je
voilà je le dis à partir de quelle somme
vous considérez comment 4000 euros net
par mois pour moi c'est des ça passe le
seuil des gens riches donc vous êtes
comme je gagne plus d'accord tu dis
comme Hollande je dis que je suis riche
et tout ça il a pas d'enfants
et puis là c'est bientôt plus de
les loyers ici sont exorbitants
en général Mathieu moi j'ai parlé plus
en capital parce que les salaires c'est
quoi pour toi quelqu'un
qui possède en actif net c'est-à-dire en
enlève les les emprunts un actif net
c'est quelqu'un qui possède 5 millions
d'euros
pour moi voilà quelqu'un qui réussit 5
millions d'euros c'est quelqu'un qui est
riche quelqu'un qui est à l'abri
c'est-à-dire quelqu'un
il est à la maison
n'existe pas besoin mais attention je ne
les ai pas je suis pas riche mais moi
j'aurais jamais j'aurais jamais la
phrase de Gilles que là encore je
pourrais gifler mais je le ferai pas
c'est un ami tu en as mis quelqu'un qui
vous dit à partir de 4000 €, est-ce
qu'il est riche encore une fois ça me va
pas parce que le principe si tu veux tu
sais un jour il va prendre des
économique très intelligent un
économiste qui avait dit en 92 on a
supprimé la première classe dans le dans
le métro et la journée ce qui lui dit on
a supprimé la première classe dans le
métro c'est une grande avancée et il
avait répondu non la grande avancée ça
aurait été de supprimer la seconde et
ben je pense qu'effectivement le
principe de ce pays c'est de les gens
qui n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent en
gagner plus que les amis vers le haut et
c'est pas toi avoir des fausses
tu vis à Paris tu es pas quelqu'un de
riche là c'est parce qu'il y a une
caméra
on n'est pas riche on n'est pas riche
mais envie de parler en général 4000
euros c'est c'est un salaire énorme
c'est le salaire rêvé de millions
d'euros
tu peux avoir la voiture que tu aimes tu
peux partir en weekend
par mois pour moi c'est être riche